this here is a test paper from a fierce
competition it is from the harvard mit
math tournament now just known as hmnt
it is an annual competition for high
school students with current harvard and
mit students writing the questions and
running the event it is intended to
encourage an interest in math but they
don't go easy on anyone it is very
prestigious and attracts about a
thousand students from around the world
i tried some of the questions and let me
just say they are very tough it is an
extension beyond what is taught in
schools so sometimes to solve these you
need far flung theorems tricks and
techniques many of which i've never
encountered before and no you don't get
a calculator each year there is a
november tournament held at harvard and
then a february or march tournament held
at mit the november one is supposed to
be easier but it's not easy at all it's
just less focused on mathematical proofs
than the february one
let me show you what some of the
questions look like
this is the november general round paper
and there are 10 questions it looks like
they get harder towards the end although
the actual points given for each
question is determined by a scoring
algorithm which takes into account how
many people got that question correct it
starts off not so bad the first question
is about four different colored dominoes
red red red blue blue red and blue blue
we're asked to find the number of ways
to arrange the dominoes in a row end to
end such that adjacent ends have the
same colour the answers provided on the
website say that the answer for this one
is four from a little bit of trial and
error and extrapolating all the
possibilities
question two is testing your ability to
manipulate an algebraic expression
the answers show that if you realize
it's useful to work with the quotient
rules you can work out the possibilities
for the answer but then in my eyes they
get a lot more difficult let's go down
to number seven and i'll read it out to
you in full
we're told that there's this function
which is defined by this expression here
if x is not in the range between minus
cube root two and zero and 0 otherwise
so when x is in that range it's 0. the
sum of all real numbers x for which f 10
of x is equal to 1 can be written like
this a plus b times root c over d
where a b c d are integers
d is positive c is square free and the
greatest common denominator of a b and d
is one
find one thousand a plus 100 b plus 10c
plus d
in brackets they say here that if n of x
is the function f of x iterated n times
i couldn't keep up with their solution
that found this different expression for
f of x implying something else and then
they reverse engineer the quadratic
formula this is the rest of the solution
here and keep in mind for this paper of
10 questions you have 50 minutes and the
idea working through this in the time
limit i just thought i just can't
i just can't you can't what i can't i
can't even you can't even what i just
can't even moving on to question 8 we
have an interesting sounding question
about an ant walking around on a circle
then question 9 about a cyclic convex
pentagon
and question 10 which is suspiciously
similar to number seven it says that
real numbers x y and z satisfy these
three expressions
the largest possible value of x y z is a
plus b root c over d where a b c d are
integers find a thousand a plus a
hundred b plus ten c plus d that sounds
very similar to the question that we had
in number seven
except this time instead of being given
a function we have these three algebraic
expressions now i was inspired to take a
look at this paper by my friend pk who
runs the channel dr pk math and he's
been solving some of these problems
lately i spoke to him about this exam in
particular and he's kindly uploaded his
fully worked solution of number 10
and after seeing how he did it i can
actually understand it pk has also
uploaded his solution for question
number seven so i'll link his videos
down in the description and you can
check them out if you want to get a more
complete view of how the solutions are
done the first thing pk does is to
define a variable k to be the largest
possible value of x y z
he then takes a look at this first
expression and factors out the x
so you have x times one plus y plus y z
is equal to one then take a look at the
second expression we could replace x y z
with
k
and then take k over to that side so
rewriting this we'd have
y plus y z is equal to 2 minus k this
left hand side is pretty similar to what
we have inside this bracket here just
with an additional one so if we wanted
to know one plus y plus y z
well that would be equal to two minus k
plus one which would be three minus k
then this would tell us that
x times
three minus k
is equal to one and we can rearrange to
get that x is equal to one over three
minus k
this is one of the three important
equations that we'll need to solve the
problem we can do very similar things to
find y and z just by changing which
expression we start that process with
going through it you'd get these as the
expressions for x y and z then if you
multiplied them all together you'd get x
y z also known as k to be this
expression
this can be multiplied out and
rearranged to give you a core tip for k
and if you manage to find the roots of
this quartic equation through a
combination of guesswork factorizing
division and the quadratic formula you'd
find that they are 1
4
and 5 plus or minus square root 17 over
2. this last root is in the form that
they told us about in the question this
a plus b root c over d and k is the
largest when we take the positive of
this so we can find our a to be 5 our b
to be 1 c 17 and d is 2. adding that all
up in the way they want would give you
the answer which is written down here as
5 2 7 2. they do it a different way in
the solutions which doesn't involve
solving a cortex but in my eyes their
first step takes a much greater leap of
imagination to think of anyway this was
just the general round and there are
plenty more rounds waiting for us
is the theme round and this will be
another 10 questions in 50 minutes i'm
not sure what the theme was here maybe
it was to be as mind-bending as possible
because all the questions start with
this phrase let n be the answer to this
problem good luck with that if you can't
find the answers to the problems
question 5 says let n be the answer to
this problem the polynomial x to the n
plus a x squared plus b x plus c has
real coefficients and exactly k real
roots
find the sum of the possible values of k
and then there's a team round on here
we've got questions such as number five
how many ways are there to place 31
nights in the cells of an 8 by 8 unit
grid so that no two can attack one
another note that a knight attacks
another knight if the distance between
the centers of their cells is exactly
root five then there's something called
the gut surround and this seems probably
the most fun of the rounds you're
working in teams and it's one of those
competitions where the team sends a
runner up to go and get the questions
and they come in these groups of three
and you don't get the next set of
questions until you finish these ones
these are a varying difficulty and the
first ones are pretty easy but i like
number three it says suppose
all the letters that spell harvard
multiplied together is equal to the
letters of mit multiplied together equal
to h times m times m times t and all of
those are equal to a hundred
then find the letters multiplied
together that make up rad trivia it's a
question of trying to make some
combination of these letters up here to
be left with these ones here
and the way it can be done is to do
harvard times mit times mit divided by
hmmt
that's a hundred
a hundred
a hundred divided by a hundred
so it's a hundred squared which is ten
thousand and if you cross out all the
letters that appear on the top and the
bottom you get rad trivia now let's take
a look at the spring tournament i
believe it's usually held in february
but last year was held in march online
instead of a general round the
individual questions here are split into
three topics we have the geometry round
with questions such as
two circles with radii 71 and 100 are
externally tangent compute the largest
possible area of a right triangle whose
vertices are each on at least one of the
circles
next is the combinatorics round with
questions such as a light pole starts at
a corner of a reflective square it
bounces around inside the square
reflecting off the square's perimeter n
times before ending in a different
corner the path of the light pulse when
traced divides the square into exactly
2021 regions
compute the smallest possible value of n
and the last individual round for spring
is the algebra and number theory round
where you'll find compute the sum of all
positive integers n for which the
expression n plus 7 over the square root
of n minus 1 is an integer it starts off
somewhat comprehensible but it devolves
into very complicated questions that i'm
not even confident i'll be able to read
out correctly and then here's the team
round for the spring tournament the big
difference here to the november
tournament is that these are proof type
questions for example show this or show
that determine with proof the value of
this expression and to see what proof
answers are kind of expected to look
like let's take a look at the solutions
provided online for each question there
tends to be multiple possible solutions
i was starting to think that whatever
high school students are able to ace
these must be extremely clever wikipedia
has a list of the winners from each year
and taking a look at it i noticed that
it wasn't uncommon for the individual
champion to win multiple years in a row
for example luke robital has won in 2021
2020 and 2018 so i looked them up and i
found he actually has a youtube channel
where he solves math problems shall i
say much more advanced than the ones i
solve on my channel i also looked up a
lot of the other names and a big trend
they saw was that a lot of them have
gone on to win sometimes multiple gold
medals at the international math
olympiad so this competition attracts
people who are already performing at the
very top level i found that most of the
more recent names were currently grad
students and mathematics either at mit
or harvard or other prestigious unis but
then scrolling all the way back to the
first few years the sky ricky won over
20 years ago
so i wondered what he was up to now and
if this is the same person then he's
currently an assistant professor working
in research mathematics and that wasn't
uncommon either a few names among the
list seem to be working in maths and i
guess after all the point of this
competition was to encourage interest in
math and to show what higher math looks
like to high school students it doesn't
surprise me that the winners who had
really immersed themselves in this want
to do more than just be interested in
math but really want to turn it into
their life and their career
thanks for watching this video and i
encourage you to go and check out dr p k
math he's got heaps of exam type videos
on his channel including the two
solutions to questions from this
tournament thanks to my patrons for
making these videos possible and a
special shout out to today's patreon cat
of the day tom